si la pire pandémie d'entre toutes la
peste noire
vers la fin du Moyen-Âge entre 1346 et
1358 la bactérie déferle sur l'Europe
elle y restera 500 ans le temps de semer
la terreur chez plusieurs générations
50% de la population périra
l'origine de la peste noire et longtemps
demeurer un mystère scientifique mais au
printemps 2022 on a appris grâce à
l'analyse de l'ADN humain ancien que la
bactérie et hersinia pestis a pris
naissance sur la route de la soie
on peut même affirmer que tout a
commencé en 138 huit ans avant que la
bactérie ne décime la population
d'Europe
comment les experts ont tiré
un cimetière situé dans l'actuel
kerghizistan en agissentrale sera leur
point de départ des tombes datées de
1338 et 1339 contenait des pitaphe mort
de pestilence
grâce à de l'ADN des dents exhumées leur
hypothèse se précisera
la pulpe dentaire se conserve bien après
la mort
elle permet donc la préservation des
pathogènes qu'il y avait dans le sang
d'après l'ADN retrouvée la bactérie qui
a causé les pestilences de ses anciens
kirguent était l'ancêtre direct de celle
qui a traversé la Méditerranée quelques
années plus tard
cette souche nommée karadjigatche aurait
donc été la première transmise à l'homme
les échanges commerciaux avec l'Europe
ont pu ensuite jouer un rôle dans la
propagation de la maladie chez les
Européens
la peste est une maladie transmise par
les rongeurs elle n'a jamais été
éradiquée de la surface de la planète
mais elle est traitée efficacement par
les antibiotiques